my guest today is michael schumer he's
an american science writer historian of
science
founder of the skeptic society which
they have 55 000 subscribers he is a
skeptic
and he wrote a book called why people
believe weird things he's got tens of
millions of views on youtube and he's
famous for saying at least for me i've
watched him uh quite a lot he says
humans created god not the other way
around we're going to find out what he
really thinks about god at this phase of
his life
[Music]
heaven said that michael thank you for
being a guest on valuetainment oh nice
to see you and thanks for having me i'm
greatly honored
yes uh i'm looking i'm really looking
forward to this conversation especially
on how you went from being a believer to
being where you are today
with the positions you have your talk
you gave on whether it's ted talks your
debates would uh not necessarily debate
you have with dennis prager was more of
a discussion but you've had many
different debates the speech you gave at
oxford was one that really stuck with me
so i'm really looking forward to getting
into it so michael if you don't mind
let's take a step back and walk us
through how you got to the point you are
today in the way you believe how you
went from believing in god and obviously
you don't believe in god anymore
well i wasn't raised religious my
parents were
non-religious so i guess you'd say
secular but they weren't anti-religious
they weren't atheists they weren't
anything
and um but i got into the born-again
evangelical christian movement in high
school so this was early 70s at cresenta
valley high
uh near your arch rivals right you went
to high school
and uh a couple of my friends are really
into this the the whole christian
movement and uh
so i just kind of followed them as you
do you know peer group influence and all
that and uh but i took it pretty
seriously i i went to the glendale
adventist and became born again i went
right up to the uh
to the table where you know the pastor
called us all up and i'm like okay i'll
give this a shot so i did it then i went
to pepperdine which is a church of
christ school and and uh it was pretty
conservative politically and religiously
no dancing on campus
can't go in the girls dorms and vice
versa and uh you know so uh that was my
uh
shall we say indoctrination or
experience and inculcation into the
christian religion and i was pretty
serious about it i took courses in the
old testament the new testament the life
of jesus the writings of c.s lewis and
so on so i know the subject pretty well
and i believed it i went door-to-door
and to witness to people and that's what
you do as an evangelical so
and then i went to graduate school and
slowly lost my religion mainly because
several factors one was
uh being in constant in science and and
the empirical
rational method of determining what's uh
justified true justified true reliable
knowledge
and um and also this i began the study
of kind of compared to world religions
and i went through my joseph campbell
stage of mythology and all that stuff
and
and uh it was clear that to me at the
time that um all religions claim to have
a solid purchase on the truth but they
often contradict each other so how do
you know which is the right one and the
answer is you don't you're an
anthropologist from mars uh studying the
world's religions earthly religions you
wouldn't be able to know which is the
correct one and and unfortunately you
know the creator of the universe wrote
more than one holy book and they don't
always agree with each other so which is
the right holy book and anyway that and
then the problem of evil i felt uh was
never
properly answered by religious people
that is why bad things happen to good
people
you know why things happen at all and we
put a moral valence on it good or evil
why is that how does that happen and
and i i never felt that the theist
arguments made much sense to me so i
just quietly gave it up i didn't
announce anything i i just just quit
talking about it and i think much to the
relief of my family because i was
constantly witnessing you you can
imagine that the obnoxious kid at the at
the family dinner table you know
constantly talking about jesus
yeah and they were and they weren't
religious again they weren't
anti-religious but you know i know they
they got sick of that so there was
probably some relief on their part there
got it can i ask you a question this is
just i'm asked uh non-secular they're
not atheists but they're not christians
they don't believe in a god they're more
agnostic would you say your parents were
agnostics themselves yeah agnostic in
the sense that uh
not that they were searching and decided
it was unknowable just i think they
didn't give it much thought my parents
weren't educated they never went to
college and they were children of the
depression and and world war two so they
you know just it just never came up i
remember i remember they did drop me off
at the presbyterian church
in la la in buckingham
more of an obligation i think like i
think we're supposed to do this for our
kids
i still i still have my bible uh from
that presbyterian church at any rate but
but it was it was not not a big deal in
our household
you're a statistician yourself right you
said when you were studying uh sciences
you you you like statistics so when you
look at why people convert or why people
uh eventually turn against god right
that you know uh not necessarily turn
against that become become an agnostic
do you notice a trend of those in your
situation not
like you explained he said look in the
world according to oxford you know 84
percent of the world believes in some
sort of a god they're part of some sort
of a religion and he said two billion is
christians i think said one billion to
two billion is catholics then you have
1.1 billion give or take our muslims
850 i think you said hindu 400 million
pluses buddhism then you got a few
hundred million million that are in
their own religions and then you got
about 10 000 different religions even
christian christianity i think he said
has 34 000 denominations if i recall
some of those statistics that you said
but walk me through
you know if a person grows up in a
christian family there's a high
likelihood they're going to be a
christian if a person grows in a lds
they're going to be an elders if they so
your parents were agnostic you became
agnostic eventually you're like you're
following the lineage like if there's
some lineage there but what do you say
to people who go from
non-believers to believers what was the
cause of that and people who went from
believers to non-believers what's the
cause of that is there a trend for both
yeah this is a big issue in uh the
psychology of religious studies you know
there are journals and scholars that
study this and the basic take is that
the number one predictor of anybody's
religiosity is that of their parents now
of course like in in any social science
issue there's no one predictor that
covers 100 percent lots of different
factors the second factor is peer group
influence
or if you have high conflict with your
parents that is you don't get along with
your parents you don't like your parents
um then you're less likely to be
influenced by them you might go the
opposite direction so highly religious
parents in conflict with their children
their children grow up to be less
religious and vice versa so
uh and then there's the influence as you
get older uh you know parental influence
starts to wane in your early teens and
and then peer groups take over and then
late teens early twenties mentors
teachers mentors uh books that you read
you know pop culture
also becomes an influence so
uh after parental or family upbringing
then then uh uh you know peer group
that's what happened to me becoming
religious and then becoming
non-religious well i went to a secular
graduate university at cal state
fullerton uh for a master's degree in
experimental psych and again this was
the 70s there was no atheist movement
and no one talked about you know science
and religion and atheism like it was a
big thing it just never came up
and so for me i realized another factor
of losing my religion was you don't have
to be religious these are good people
thoughtful people moral people and
they're just not religious or maybe they
are who knows i mean it just never came
up it was not important
and uh so that made it kind of what's
called social proof you know it's okay
to not believe
because other people don't believe and
their lives are are fine so that you
know that so of course individually you
know lots of people um
you know start off as atheists francis
collins the head of the national
institutes of health and
the head of the human genome project
before that super smart guy he was an
atheist and became an evangelical and
wrote a book about it the language of
god you know so of course there's
individual cases where there's none of
the influences i'm talking about they
his case he had just a personal
experience a revelatory experience you
know i was out on a hike on a cold day
and i saw this frozen waterfall and i
fell to my knees and you know i felt the
presence of jesus he writes about this
in this book okay so there's lots of
those kind of one-off events that people
have and and then of course there's the
always popular you know down on your
luck you know life is hard and bad
things bad things happen i remember i
met isaac hayes the singer once he's a
scientologist and i knew he was a
scientologist and and i've been pretty
critical of scientology but you know
he's a was a super nice guy's
thanksgiving dinner at a mutual friend
of ours so i just asked him isaac what
you know what what does scientology do
for you
and he said well michael let me tell you
i you know i had made it to the top you
know i was rich i was a famous you know
musician
and uh
and so on you know you want a a
you know award for his theme from shaft
the music from that film and
big star lost it all
you know the typical story of you know
drugs and
and uh all the trappings that go with
being a big star and he lost it all in
scientology helped him get his life back
together
so there's a lot of those kind of
stories so level of loyalty to the
religion that kind of got you when
you're at the lowest level
yes and uh you know to that i say well
good you know whatever it takes to get
through life i understand i'm not a
militant atheist where i think you know
everybody always
must give up their religion some people
just find it comforting and they're not
making any empirical claims that this is
true in any ontological sense like this
is the true nature of the universe it
includes this particular god no they're
just saying look uh it just works for me
okay it helped me and and i like these
people and a story a little bit like uh
maybe if you're a democrat or a
republican
you know it's it that that's not always
a matter of who has the best arguments
in fact research on political science
and and preferences of what people
choose it often turns
around what kind of people you like to
be around what are their values and
which party kind of best represents
those kind of people and those kind of
values not the particular uh planks in
the platform of that
particular election for that party and
it's a little bit like that and we do
know from behavior genetic studies on
twins separated from birth and to what
extent
uh these kinds of things are heritable
temperament personality that you know
people migrate toward political parties
and religions that make them feel good
that that jives with their temperament
with their openest experience their
conscientiousness their you know
introversion extroversion their you know
their sense of right and wrong and you
know and just the kind of people that
they like to be around you know it's
it's fun to debate people that you
disagree with but it's not fun to hang
around them all the time you know i
wouldn't want to be married to somebody
who you know was you know the complete
opposite of me politically religiously
and so on it would just get tiring right
so just kind of extrapolate that out you
know who do you like to just hang around
with and
uh and that's also an influence how
about flip it flip it so that's how
people give their lives how they have a
spiritual moment with a god right with
their own god whoever that may be
flip it to
stories of people who were believers
that became non-believers what caused
that event
um well so there's not as much research
on deconversion there's quite a bit of
research on conversion and summarize
some of that deconversion there's not
much
there's some research going on now on
the nuns the so-called people that have
no religious affiliation they tick the
box for none
under religious in surveys and polls and
and uh you know it
there's some influence of education for
example more educated people or slightly
less religious but not in a huge way
like you know if you have a graduate
degree you're highly likely to be an
atheist no not not like that at all
and interestingly the the just the last
decade the the percentage of nuns is
more than doubled it's about about a
quarter of all americans and about a
third of millennials that is people born
after 1981 uh have no religious
affiliation
they're the fastest growing religious
cohort in the country no religious
affiliation
now my atheist friends go aha they're
you know they're to be atheists well no
not necessarily it's looking more more
like they're turning to more
shall we say secular religions you know
buddhism western buddhism meditation
uh you know the kind of people that go
to deepak troper center and in carl's
bed or they go to esselon institute
where they find a lot of new age
uh spiritual beliefs that are not
religiously related and they don't
believe in a personal god necessarily
but
some kind of higher force or some kind
of
entity or something that exists beyond
us but it usually remains poorly defined
or not defined at all
i mean there's got to be a trend though
because for me i think about i was born
in iran so war happens i see a bunch of
people die
uh i'm uh uh seeing stuff that i don't
want to really see i go to church every
time my mom and dad take me to church i
get kicked out of sunday school i keep
asking one question from my sunday
school teacher that she can't answer
it's a basic question
if god so loved the world why is why are
we having so many people die because of
war why did we get bombed 165 times the
other day if he loves
us so much why did this happen well you
know finally she calls my mom and dad
and saying your son can no longer mean
bible study because for four straight
weeks she couldn't answer one basic
question right so i go to germany i see
some behavior by a
armenian pastor that completely turned
me off from uh
a certain way he was behaving around my
family didn't like that and i called him
out on it and i was a 10 11 year old kid
he didn't like that too much but you
know it's uh i'm my father's son and i'm
a protector and then we come to the
states go to the army i'm still an
atheist 25 years of my life i'm an a i'm
an atheist right
so then eventually i study everything
scientology i do whatever i can get my
hands on because i'm curious lds
mormonism joseph smith jehovah you read
the books case for christ case for
church all these things
but i also saw a trend
why believers became non-believers
typically
there was a letdown by either a
religious leader
who set the example
and
he did something you know whether it's a
behavior
normally it's uh it's a what do you call
it a girl a woman you know kid drugs he
wants to leave the life so you're
disappointed oh my god i cannot believe
this pastor did this there's no way in
the world i'm going to be catholic
christian so you leave the life right
typically it's a disappointment by a
father figure somebody in the family but
there's also a heartbreak when they pray
because they lose a loved one and that
absolutely crushes them right where they
sit and say look i pray for this you
didn't answer my question why am i going
to believe in god would you mind sharing
the story of maureen with the audience
for them to kind of uh
and tell me if that had any effects for
you because i can tell you for me
that was my biggest disappointment
because i lost a loved one what kind of
an effect did i have on your faith
yeah yeah sure i'll share that story
momentarily i think you've tapped into
though a huge issue that is that what's
called the odyssey or the problem of
evil why bad things happen to good
people now theists will argue well the
examples you just gave
of war that's human cause that we
attribute to agency free will humans
have free will god gave us free will and
we made bad choices so too bad
that and that goes back to the fall in
the garden uh when you know adam and eve
and that whole story that we are by
nature sinful and that's part of the
sinful nature
uh that uh theists
are willing to agree we have and and so
things like war homicide
genocide rape torture so on you know
those are human caused okay
so that's one thing but and that i agree
with you that is problematic from a uh
you know a theistic point of view but
they do have a response to that but they
don't have a good response to in my
opinion
is natural evil that is tsunamis
earthquakes childhood leukemia i mean
just take that one or just just take the
thousands of children that die every
year from starvation
i mean we know what they need
and uh you know the bill gates of the
world can only do so much why can't god
do what bill gates does i mean why can't
he help it you know this is these are
like a one-year-old what kind of
volition an agency does a one-year-old
have who gets you know leukemia and dies
a horrible miserable life suffering and
the parents suffer for the rest of their
lives losing their children
and uh at these in my opinion do not
have a good answer to that so i think
you've made a correct
deduction there and in the case you
asked about maureen was my girlfriend in
uh at pepperdine and
for several years after in graduate
school and so on and she got in a bad
car accident and broke her back and uh
this was the sweetest wonderful smartest
nicest woman i knew and i just could not
believe that this happened and i was
kind of in the transition from leaving
to leaving my religion and becoming a
non-believer but for a moment i thought
you know what i'm just gonna pray for
her because you know maybe there is a
god what do i know and uh you know if
anybody deserves to be healed it's her
and i you know you talk to a million
christians and you'll get a million
stories of you know people that are
miraculously healed you know they prayed
to god and god you know reached into the
world and and performed a miracle why
not why not her well of course nothing
happened and she's still paralyzed to
this day and so it's like why that now i
wasn't putting god to some you know test
it wasn't a public thing i didn't write
about it for decades afterwards
and um but i just thought you know what
that's a good
i know one last nail in the coffin so to
speak of the death of god for me
was you know i think it's more likely
that just bad things happen that they do
just you know as the bumper sticker says
happens it's the second law of
thermodynamics it's entropy you know
there's just more ways for things to go
wrong than things to go right just think
of a sand castle at the beach you know
how many how many ways are there to push
grains of sand together into something
that looks like a castle not many
compared to the near infinite ways the
grains could be molded into just
featureless lumps
and that's a metaphor for the human body
just way more things to go wrong than
right
and and so people get cancer just
randomly it's just there's no meaning
behind it at all
and and if there is a god and he's all
good and all powerful then it's an
indictment
that he's not all good if he doesn't do
anything about it so that's my take on
that you know it's like anything you
debate so i'm sitting there debating
somebody on the topic of guns
and there's no way i can win this debate
i'm like why is this person debating it
with me in such a strong way there's no
matter what i say this woman's not gonna
and he eventually realized you know her
kid her husband they believed in guns
they let the gun out the kid grabs it
and shoots herself and boom i mean that
no matter how the more you debate this
person
on the freedoms of gun and second
amendment the more she's hating you the
more she's like the more so there's no
winning that debate right so for me
there's not a black and white in this
when it comes down to talking because
everyone's got a little bit of a
different story and that's personal the
only thing you know is your life the
only thing i know is my life the only
thing we know is to get our and then
whatever books we get our hands on it's
kind of tough to get to the truth
uh uh on the other way around but
if you don't mind taking the argument
that you made i thought it was so
profound i wouldn't mind you unpacking a
little bit more where you said if
there's all these arguments if there's
all these uh uh uh two billion
christians you got 1.1 muslims why is it
that those 1.1 muslims believe everybody
else who doesn't believe in their god is
an atheist or you know the argument you
were making
would you mind going through that
argument on
why you think people man created god
rather than god created man
yeah sure uh i'll do that in a moment
but you brought up a good example of
guns guns
are another religious like
uh value that people hold it's in my
opinion because i've done a number of
gun debates i think we do need some gun
control even though i used to be against
gun control as a former libertarian now
classical liberal i i've discovered that
people um
that gun belief in guns is a proxy for
something else for freedom for liberty
for the american way for for some deeper
value
so in that extent it doesn't matter how
many people are shot every year and
homicides accidental
uh childhood uh you know guns going off
and things like that it's irrelevant
there's no amount of people that could
die that's gonna
change the way they feel about guns
because it's not about the guns it's
about the second amendment it's about
constitution freedom liberty autonomy uh
self-defense and you know these kind of
deeper
features and and it's a lot of religious
truths work that way
and so it's whenever you're talking to
somebody about politics or religion it's
always good to figure out
what's the deeper moral value behind the
specific thing they're talking about
immigration or abortion or whatever
because they're you're if they're if
they're pretty stubborn and stuck
uh on the belief that and they're not
going to change because it represents
something deeper then it's really a
waste of time to go through like this
data and statistics on gun violence or
abortion rates or immigration rates or
whatever it doesn't matter
and i think religions operate that way
you know that this is my religion this
is what i believe that's it we'll stop
uh i'm not interested in debating it and
you could go through like atheists do
they go through the all the different
arguments for god and why they don't
hold water and therefore it's more
likely there's not a god than there is a
god and so on but that's irrelevant to
somebody that believes for some other
reason you know this gives my meaning my
life meaning or purpose it's what my
family is all about it's all my friends
and my social network are all of this
religion i see everybody every week and
and we all go through the rituals
together and it gives my life meaning
and the good good music and the social
camaraderie
um so the arguments that you might make
like i will in just a moment uh are
really irrelevant to the believer so
now on that subject of man creating god
so here i take the approach of an
anthropologist or a social psychologist
of religion which of which there are
many who study this that
um again going through where we started
with you know the predictors of people's
religiosity but it also depends uh if
you take it up one more scale
uh where you happen to have been born in
the world and what century you were born
in or what millennium uh you know if we
were born you and i or anybody in the
world anybody born more than uh say 2500
years ago at the time of the ancient
greeks there were no christians you
wouldn't be a christian because christ
wasn't born yet jesus wasn't born yet
there were no christians and uh or
mormons or scientologists or anything
else so very much you know religion very
much
the god you happen to believe in
is very much determined by where on
earth you happen to have been born by
chance
and what century or millennium you
happen to be born to me
that in conjunction with the fact that
no religion has any particular purchase
on truth that is
uh reliable uh knowledge that that i
have arrived at through
empiricism and reason
and these are the six reasons i i
believe x whatever it is and there's
some way to test it
religion doesn't have anything like that
i mean religious believers give their
arguments this is why i believe but it
isn't really why they believe they
believe for these other emotional
psychological reasons and
and again in some cases that's okay like
politically you know there's there's no
one right truth there but um but the
problem arises when religions claim that
they have absolute truth so in your case
you know in iran you know so you have
you have religious conflicts there with
no way to resolve the problem or if you
want to just turn to the israeli arab
israeli problem you know basically you
got to two guys with they both have a
deed to the same piece of land and
there's no escrow company to go to to
resolve who actually owns it right
because the escrow company is god and
each of them says i have a direct line
to god he told me this is mine and each
of them says that and the anthropologist
from mars goes well which one of you is
right and they just go well i'm right
and the other guy goes i'm right and
there's no way to resolve it there's no
experiment we're gonna run to go oh
you're the right one the other one's the
wrong one so they get the land
historically these things are always
settled you know violently through
through war conflict
and but we can't do that anymore because
of nuclear weapons so
uh so we're probably going to be stuck
with this israeli arab problem short of
a two-state solution which is the only
way i i i can see could ever be resolved
you know asking somebody you know could
we pay you
for this particular piece of land you
know it it it's almost like asking
somebody how much they would charge for
sex or for dinner you know if you have
friends to have you over for dinner what
can i pay you you know it's just that's
a sacred value you don't put money on it
and uh so you know there's a whole suite
of
of uh beliefs like this like organ
donations you know why not sell your
organs well people are very
uncomfortable with this idea and same
thing with prostitution most people are
not comfortable you know and and you
know sex workers
that charge for their services
you know that used to be called
prostitution which has a negative
valence to it because
again people have certain sacred valley
values that they'll never give up that
you can't put a price on
and uh and there we that you know that
explains much of the world's conflict i
think
so man created god
not the other way around god that's what
that's what it looks like to me i mean
you know if you kind of lay it out the
different claims made by the different
religions that are in conflict with one
another
uh
and the fact that you know flood myths
are common amongst religions that you
know were born and raised
that is the religion on a body of water
that floods right or resurrection myths
you know christians claim our ours is
unique you know because we have the
resurrection no that's not true there's
lots of religions with resurrected gods
and the theme of resurrection comes up a
lot
uh either literally or metaphorically
and you know almost all born of a virgin
you know that this is also not unique to
christianity there's lots and lots of
examples of
of deities that are born of virgins and
you know god's having sex with humans in
the in the ancient uh
greek and roman world around the time
christianity came came online that was
very calm god's god's routinely came
down from the heavens had sex with
mostly women
and uh you know then the result were the
virgin births right you know this was
not unusual at the time
and men could become gods or partial
gods and gods could become humans or
partial humans you know so this whole
business that uh that critics of
christianity have about how can you
believe that jesus was
with was both god and the son of god how
can that be
you know there's a problem of identity
you can't be both at the same time well
in the roman times when christianity was
born that was quite common gods could
routinely uh have sex and and become a
human for a while and then return to
becoming just gods and and go back to
being human or partial human and that
was actually a common belief so to me
all elements of all the religions
uh are obviously socially constructed
you know people made them made up these
stories
so so two follow-up questions for that
so
in in the story of virgin mary right
when jesus was born and we read the
bible in your mind based on the bible
that you read and you studied
did she say
i was not with anybody i'm a virgin i've
never been with a man
and then the story came about meaning
what is the sequencing in your uh ideas
because yes a lot of people at that time
can claim and say look i didn't get
pregnant i'm telling you i didn't do it
i have sex with anybody it was a guy
that came and i'm pregnant the question
would be
what are the chances of her saying that
and her son being
jesus christ
that's a mathematical question that's
more statistically you know the chances
of her saying yeah i'm telling you i
wasn't with anybody this is god's work
like okay mary you know you're full of
it you have no idea what you're talking
about i'm telling you this is not me and
then boom
one point one out of 113 billion people
being born her kid becomes jesus what's
it so what's that it can't be okay i see
these are in my mind two independent
uh events they're they're not
necessarily tied together
we don't know we don't we you know
people that study ancient roman gods uh
you know can list off some of these
names that are not at the top of my head
but uh but there was another one um
let's see um oh shoot a tiana
forget his name 25 100 2500 years before
it happened to jesus there's another
story like that well no no around the
same time actually uh at the same
century um and uh anyways his name is
escaping me now but but but uh but there
were lots of of individuals like this
who claimed that they were born of a
virgin
uh were persecuted by authorities were
put to death were raised you know from
the dead and went to heaven and so on
the jesus story is not the only one so
you can't put a calculation on it and
then and then combine these two
independent events the virgin birth and
but the difference is jesus you know one
of them and you can't think of the other
person's name so there's there's lots of
them there's
what i'm saying to you is no no what i'm
saying i know you say there's a lot of
my skeptic side i'm more skeptic than
i'm a believer
i'm more on the skeptical side on the
believer's side but i'm also a math guy
what is the likelihood of a person
saying that and the son
ends up becoming who he is and has two
billion people
fought on this guy well again these are
independent uh events
jesus didn't become jesus because
of the virgin birth or anything like
that it's because of paul
and even there
you have to really trace for about two
centuries how christianity became the uh
the the state religion uh under
constantine in the fourth century
uh
it's
no late fourth century
and uh
and and and and you only need like a one
and a half two percent uh conversion
rate or birth rate it within a religion
for it to grow from you know a few tens
of people to a few tens of millions of
people to a few hundred million people
by the fifth century all the way up till
today to two billion people that's like
compound interest so it doesn't take a
miracle to explain the growth of
religion same thing
you can't say the same thing but the
argument you're making could be made for
islam is just
one of the chances that muhammad in the
7th century
and his particular unique story would
end up
you know in the 21st century with a
billion and a half followers no no but
that's not what i'm saying no no that's
not no no there's two by the way if you
want to do that math then we have to go
back to hindu which i think is 2300 bc
and then uh buddhism that's 2500 bc how
come they're both smaller than muslim
and christianity then the debate becomes
well then if that's the case muslim is
creating more momentum than any other
religion in the world so we can have
that discussion i've done that as well
because yeah that's completely separate
where i'm going with you is the
following
i'm going to
a guy gets up and he says
here's who i am this is what's going to
happen a woman is pregnant
she says i'm telling you i didn't hook
up with anybody
like what are you talking about
of course you're going to claim
something like that you're out of your
mind i'm telling you
this is not i didn't do anything i'm a
virgin whatever i don't know what's
going on this could be something special
here
yours lady we find out it's jesus and
the chances of that to be two billion
people you can't say well it's that easy
any religion could do it as long as they
grow one and a half percent of weekend
well but that's the hindsight bias
you're taking the one that that won out
and ignoring all the other ones that uh
that didn't become major all i'm saying
is the
it's it's the chances of a virgin mother
and she makes the claim then the son
becomes who she said he was going to
become that's a very
that's a very uh uh it's a little bit
spooky if i can use the word because
even as a skeptic myself you sit there
and say what are the chances of that so
i'm not going to what prophet muhammad
said i'm not going to what anybody else
and i'm specifically using that
situation we don't have any other story
like that that got as big as this one
did
well but again you're you're picking out
the the hindsight bias you're picking
out the one that happened to
uh be successful you have to look at all
the ones that have the same story that
didn't become successful why didn't they
you say
so maybe so that's a question for you
though not for me here it is i i found
it i was looking at my slides here
apollonius of tyanna he's a first
century a.d living in asia minor his
followers claimed he was the son of god
that he was able to walk through closed
doors heal the sick cast out demons and
raise the dead girl back to life he was
accused of witchcraft sent to rome
before the court was jailed but escaped
after he died his followers claimed he
appeared to them and then ascended to
heaven
so
now this is around the same time as
jesus and jesus didn't become a big
thing until again centuries later you
know the gospels themselves were not
even written for the earliest one mark
was 40 years after jesus death the
others 50 60 70 90 years
and uh and i'll just give you some other
examples here virgin birth myths um
these these are deities who were born of
a virgin dionysus perseus buddha atis
krishna horus mercury romulus and jesus
dionysius is the ancient greek god said
to have been born from a virgin woman
fathered by the king of heaven to have
transformed water into wine introduced
the idea of eating and drinking the
flesh and blood of god
was the liberator of his people and to
have returned from the dead
resurrection myths the egyptian god of
life death and fertility was osiris so
this is 2400 bce that appears in the
first pyramid text
he was he was considered to be the giver
of life in this world the redeemer and
merciful judge of the dead in the next
world
egyptian kings believed that as osiris
rose from the dead so would they in
union with him inheriting eternal life
and by the new kingdom everyone believed
that if they accepted osiris as their
god they too would be resurrected which
one of them has two million two billion
people that well so there you're making
an argument for uh you know populist
argument that you know whoever whoever
has the most adherence is more likely to
be right so christianity about one and a
half times more likely than israel no i
know i simply give you a point i
are you a sports guy or no are you a
person
i'm a big sports guy okay which one tell
me which sport oh i i follow the you
know nfl and the nba all that's pretty
good so
so that's the nba okay let's go nba
who's the greatest basketball player of
all time well it's got to be cream
you go so you say kareem okay
but i'll go with michael jordan too okay
but i think you you make it interesting
if you keep it kareem right okay
give me your top five so so let's just
say kareem and michael are top two who's
well if we're going with pre uh current
players because lebron obviously has to
be on the list okay let's look on there
as well so you got two okay lebron yeah
okay so and i guess i would put uh magic
johnson okay
you know a great player and also
charismatic and and you know change the
game
um and uh probably larry bird just to
throw in you know one white guy
well it's good to know you don't
discriminate i respect
so now let's go with that now you said
kareem tell me why korean because i
think kareem is a very easy argument as
the greatest of all time but what's your
argument for korean being the greatest
of all time well it's good because the
top top scorer of all time and also
number championships and and you know a
true motivated leader of his teams
and he'd dominate a game you know
college nba
you know revolutionary type of a player
he couldn't be consistent yeah number of
mvps number of these things that he did
okay so all i'm saying to you is i'm not
saying
that single event is the reason why
kareem abdul-jabbar's agree you know how
they say michael jordan's the greatest
of all time because he went to six
championships and he never lost one i
think that's one point but i don't think
that alone is enough of a catalog to
call him the greatest of all time right
so lebron's been to more championships
then you have to go to bill russell
but to say that your mother was a virgin
and you were born and you got two
billion followers i think that gets a
point i don't know if that says you are
the greatest of all time
i see i see where you're going with this
yeah now i i'm afraid i can't agree with
that because you don't have to agree
with that
we just got to give a point there i
think there are independent variables
there anyway so now let me give you the
point for the opposite side here's the
point for for the opposite side
uh
uh oh and i'm going to give you a soft
one here you know just see what you're
going to say about this so
so many people that are educated that
have degrees smart folks you mentioned
paul earlier oh jesus became big because
of apostle paul he was a pretty big
skeptic and he was saul before he was
paul right so he's a
he wasn't just a lightweight guy and he
was a true believer later on without him
you know him and billy graham probably
compete for who baptized the most people
some say billy some say him it is what
it is
what do you say to those who say
michael
super educated people like c.s lewis who
wrote mere christianity oxford
university professor the guy didn't
believe in anything he wrote the
chronicles of narnia then he flips and
he becomes one of the biggest you know
believers of the the religion of
christianity to the point where any
church that
baptizes and brings new members on the
first book they read of cost of
discipleship the second book they read
is mere christianity why is an educated
man like
you know c.s lewis later on in life that
you're supposed to get smarter the
smarter he got the more he flipped why
and you studied c.s lewis why yes yes
yes well again these are in in
individual cases everyone's different i
mentioned um
uh earlier the language of god francis
collins story and uh
yeah cs lewis is similar in fact francis
collins cites c.s lewis as an example
because he was obviously such a smart
guy
frankly amongst the theologians that is
really serious super professional
theologians that you know they don't
think c.s lewis is all that serious as a
theologian even though they share their
beliefs not that i'm
able to make that assessment but uh just
for what that's worth okay why i don't
know you know he um he wrote a beautiful
book called the grief observed about his
wife who died of cancer again
you know he grapples with the problem of
evil the odyssey did you ever see the
movie did you see yeah oh yeah of course
yeah yeah yeah joy was her name right
joy something i think yeah
he died from cancer and it really
questioned his faith
right yes no no it's an incredible so i
think anthony hopkins plays c.s lewis
crushed it yeah i mean yeah and uh
deborah winger plays joy it's it's a
it's a great film
yeah so there again you know i don't
fault anybody for
you know
wanting or needing or desiring religion
or claiming it on some level
for what it's worth one of the leader
top
modern skeptics martin gardner he was
one of the founders of the modern
skeptic movement long time monthly
columnist before me at scientific
american
wrote many books about uh arguments for
and against god and he himself said well
i think atheists have better arguments
than the theists do for god's existence
but i believe in god
and it was like what
and he called himself a deist or a
pragmatist
theist is the correct term but the
pragmatist that is there are pragmatic
reasons for believing in god that have
to do with emotion
emotional need and meaningfulness
purposefulness in life and sense you
can't prove there is no god and it's one
of a handful of mysterious mysteries as
they're called like free will and
determinism you know scientists tell us
that the universe is determined
from whence comes volition or free will
well i i i feel free so i i'm i i think
of it as a useful fiction you know and
maybe god is like that for some people
and i and i think some i think it's
something like that for c.s lewis
although i don't recall exactly uh it's
been so long since i studied him that
that what his uh reasoning was
personally everyone has a personal story
and uh so i think probably it was
something along those lines
got it uh you know uh in in regards to
um
in regards to
uh
religion like you know years ago for me
i was sitting there debating with
somebody at rafi's place and this lady
and her husband were telling me you know
uh uh this is the word of god this is
the truth you know this is uh you know
a hundred percent the truth i sat there
and i said so let me let me get this
straight so you got the bible from day
one till today how many times has it
been you know how many different
versions have we had how many different
translations that we have how many
different times has it been said you
know rewritten different languages do
you not lose some meaning to it until it
becomes
uh uh uh english right and that's the
skeptic's uh point of view you expect to
believe this right how is this even
possible for this to stay exactly what
was said at that time well you know this
is the word of god but the part i would
go with you is a little bit different
than that one
do you think religion was in a way used
at that time to try to control
uh the naive populace where it was
easier to do then than it is today
well um okay there's
there's many different theories to
explain um
you know the origins of religion this is
one of them you know the kind of control
of population control of people sort of
enforce or reinforce
um
moral values and and uh norms of the
society
it's a way of saying look even if you
know you think you got away with it
uh from our our police force or whatever
you know there's an eye in the sky that
sees everything so that's one element of
religion uh the other is more social
capital that is to say it's a way it you
know if you particularly like just think
of the founding fathers of the united
states and they argued that
uh for a a self-governing people
a self-governing society to operate
people need an internal governor
uh and they need some kind of uh value
moral value system and religion is one
of those now the founding fathers were
mostly diaz so they made an argument
from aristotle's virtue ethics that is
there's value in in developing virtuous
characteristics in your children and
yourself and then we'll have a society
of virtuous people and therefore you
don't need so much government or
religion
but but of course that's pretty late in
the game
both religion and governments came about
around the same time around the axial
age maybe
five six thousand years ago
when these you know kind of chiefdoms
bands tribes and chieftains began to
coalesce into larger states and empires
you needed a way of resolving social
conflict so you have a set of rules and
laws you gotta have a police force in a
court system some kind of judicial
system the state has to be able to
impose punishments or else what's the
point of having rules because people
will violate them
and and and religion at the same time
you know if you have just 10 people or
50 people living in a small community
you can all just meet it you know every
friday in the commons and and talk about
your problems but if you have millions
of people you can't do that you need
some kind of social institutions to do
that so religion is one of those
so that's that kind of general
explanation that historians and
sociologists of religion offer
this is a vital role of religion uh is
to kind of hold people together and now
in the modern world
let's say in post-world war two europe
where you've seen this massive decline
of religiosity
uh almost flipped in in a matter of
decades from almost everybody believing
to
you know only a small percentage of true
believers and churches falling into
into disuse a lot of them are empty
these major cathedrals are more like art
art museums now
and uh you know and and like even in
germany where my wife is from you know
the catholic church is just bleeding
members particularly after the whole
pedophile thing you know people are just
just had enough and uh
but see european societies are different
they have a than america they have much
tighter social safety net because one of
the real roles of religion over the
centuries has been to take care of the
poor
which before the before capitalism and
the industrial revolution almost
everybody was poor you know 90 of the
world was poor right so this is one of
the major roles of religion but in the
20th century
um most governments today including the
united states have a about about a
quarter about 20 percent of their gdp
is allocated toward uh social services
you know welfare social security you
know food stamps aid for poor families
and so forth uh that's actually pretty
common even though you'll hear
conservatives complain bitterly about
the numbers too high or liberals
complaining that the number is too low
it's about the same as most european
countries so uh the social safety net is
kind of taking over the role of religion
which leaves america as something of an
outlier how come religion hasn't
declined as much or as rapidly in
america as in european countries
and and one answer is because we have
the first amendment that forbids the
relig the government the state from
getting involved in religion so
religions have undertaken to become
pretty expert at marketing their
products and services they're really
good at if you've ever been to a mega
church
uh which i have several times it's quite
the show it's i mean they're offering
a lot to their people i mean it is
really fun to go to it's you know music
and free parking
and lots of community and and uh you
know and people like that and so it's
not just
i need somebody to tell me what's right
or wrong or the meaning of life or
whatever there's a lot more to it than
that socially let me let me uh uh ask
this other question for you to uh see
you think the country based on a
christian religion or
uh a peaceful religion does better than
a country that doesn't have a religion
uh well this you know there's there are
studies on this that
uh the more uh religious
a
nation or society
um the
less healthy the society is now how is
health measured quantitatively what
we're talking about here are things like
um abortion rates teen pregnancy rates
std rates homicide rates suicide rates
um you know like infant mortality
there's about 15 of these different
characteristics and a social scientist
named gregory paul
did this massive correlational study of
like the top 20 uh industrial
democracies in the world as measured and
then measured by their religiosity as
measured by
you know what percentage of the
population says they believe in god they
attend uh
church services you know every week they
read the bible every day and so forth
and you know basically it's an inverse
correlation the the higher the
religiosity the lower the rates of these
um
social health measures that is to say
like in america is a standout you know
we have the world's highest
among these 20 democracies
you know we're the most religious but we
have the highest rates of homicides
highest rates of suicides highest rates
of stds uh pregnancies unwanted
pregnancies uh abortions you know
teen problems uh infant mortality and so
on
now each of these i have to say
parenthetically each of these has an
independent
series of causes that have nothing to do
with religion
but my point is that if religion is such
a great prophylactic against social ills
that if a society needs it to be a
healthy happy society how come it's the
opposite in america we're the most
religious that and we have the most
social problems of any of these
countries on those measures and so to me
it's like it's whatever religion's doing
it's not doing that it's not helping
so you think the country's better off
without without a religion absolutely
yes really
yeah yeah as long as they have of course
you got to have some kind of social
safety net you got to have a set of
standards and values that people go on
so my christian friends say yeah even if
every no one believed in god in america
we're still a judeo-christian society
from historically okay that's true so so
then you would much rather trust in
a man's values and principles that
dictate the country than a
set of principles based on a book or a
bible
you'd much rather have a man lead your
country really oh yeah because
i think about the constitution yeah the
enlightenment values
this this whole centuries-long
experiment has been one of of saying
regardless of whatever your religion is
these are the values we hold that we
that people are are born equal that is
of equal value and should be treated
equally under the law
and we're going to abolish slavery and
torture and civil rights and women's
rights and gay rights and all the things
you know we've kind of experienced in
our own lifetime
peace came about
because of this central principle of
interchangeable perspectives there's
nothing special about me or my religion
or my race that that makes me better
than you and your religion and your race
are equal
is
in terms of value so that is an
enlightenment principle no religion came
up with that and in fact religion has
come up with quite the opposite
you know that our religion is the one
true religion and back to where you were
talking about earlier in the
conversation you know all these wars the
ones you personally experienced growing
up that's because of religions conflict
with each other and no means i think the
complete opposite though i think it's
the complete opposite i think what
you're saying is
you know what america was founded on the
constitution you know where they got it
from
you know where they got it from well
okay uh you're gonna say they got it
from the bible but no actually the
founding fathers were mostly deists
uh jefferson hamilton no i'm not going
to say the bible but do you know where
they got it from okay go ahead i'm
curious i'm asking you but what do you
think they got it from what's the
history
so the constitution did they come up
with
all of them were classically trained so
they knew history they knew greek and
they knew the history of greece and
particularly rome so if you read the
federalist papers for example there's
just example after example between
hamilton and madison of uh examples from
ancient greece and rome yep and they
knew these histories and then of course
they're the products of the
enlightenment they were in the
enlightenment you know so
you know john locke and and um john
jacques rousseau and thomas hobbes and
all the thinkers that kind of
particularly locked that that led to
this division of
of uh separation of powers because and
if you read the federalist papers
they're very much steeped in human
nature they start off going like what
are people like people are selfish they
are power hungry if you let them they
will take more than they need do you
believe that
oh yeah totally absolutely so if you
believe that if you believe that how
would you trust more
of a man coming up his values and
principles to run your country than a
higher power that you can't change it
because the higher and i'm purely
talking from a logical standpoint
how do you know what happens but the
problem is how do you know what the
higher power thinks
here's a part of me there's a part of me
that actually doesn't care
there's a part of me that can't but you
have to care because i'm going to ask
you well where'd you get that particular
idea you got to say what it comes from
the bible well here's why let me explain
to you why let me explain to you so how
sure are you about your beliefs
about what about the fact that you think
a man created god not the other way
around i'm reasonably confident and sort
of a bayesian say i'd say 18 to 90
percent okay great you think there's
people on the opposite side that are
also at 80 or 90 percent
i'd say there's religious people that
are a hundred percent yeah i would say
atheists i think they're 100 which to me
the atheist argument is the most famous
no no no no no no no no no no no the
atheist is just a lack of belief in god
it doesn't mean because the strong
atheist it says i know there is no god
is not a tenable position you don't know
there's no god all you can do is put a
probable that's right we're on the same
page there yeah yeah so
agnostic to me is the one that says
you know they they don't know right but
the atheist says i know there is no god
well the weak okay there's the strong
atheist that says i know there is no god
that's not a tenable position in my
opinion the weak atheist says i just
don't believe in god uh now there might
be and if i could change my mind or you
know i might find out later but okay for
now i i i just assume there isn't and
unless proven otherwise okay but that
doesn't tell you anything about what
somebody believes you know and say well
what do you believe in well i believe in
civil rights and civil liberties and i
believe in love and you know whatever
that has nothing to do with atheism
completely there's but there's one thing
a religion that's 100 percent proven
that's proven it's a hundred percent
right you know what religion that is
the religion of i don't know
okay all right yes or no i mean that's
that's 100 proven so meaning
meaning you can say you believe in
jesus he can say he believes in prophet
muhammad she can say she believes in
whoever i can say guys listen we can sit
here and fight all we want and put
events together in halls and gather a
thousand people and sell 100 tickets and
you and i can debate all day long and
the answer at the end of the day is what
neither one of us know right okay so if
we know we know that's the only hundred
percent
is that we don't know let's set that
aside if we know we're going off of
you're never going to be 100 right i'm
never going to be 100 right till we die
we're not going to know right so as long
as we're living and we have the religion
of i don't know
what do we want to base the country off
of let's pick a manual this manual
called bible works we have the bible
what's the book that elrond hubbard
wrote dianetics we have uh the quran we
have the book of moroni whichever book
you want to pick we have pick any of the
books we have buddhism you know great
book i've read it that's very to me it's
it's it's if i wasn't a christian i'd
probably be a buddhist
you know let's take all these books
let's take uh meditations by uh what do
you call it by uh our friend uh the
stoic system marcus aurelius right
martin luther king
yes
let's pick one of these books michael
and let's build the foundation of the
country of this one person and let's not
even look at it as a god let's look at
it as a philosopher and a way of living
don't you think it's better to pick a
book of a person that's not alive
to go live life off of that than a
person that's alive that can all of a
sudden have a meltdown and change and
become a dictator
no the the
the correct the correct answer is
you don't base a you don't base a
constitution on any book no book no book
the whole point of the u.s constitution
what makes it unique amongst all
political systems ever invented is that
it's not based on any book it's based on
a set of principles derived through
reason and then open to change
you know as as madison said ambition
must be made to counteract ambition
people have their preferences
the jew the christian the muslim they
each want as much power as they can get
so we have to have a rule in there that
says nobody gets to have any
state-sanctioned religion there are no
religions state sanctioned by the state
full stop you can believe whatever you
want but it can't influence our
political system done okay next you know
well i you know that my race should be
the superior race okay well we kind of
messed that up in the with the slavery
thing but but you know we got that
eventually solved through a civil war
and so on so but but so the whole
principle is based on ideas not
people's
books not holy books not revelation
you know you can't if you were to write
a new constitution today you wouldn't
start off saying well we begin with that
jesus is our savior
and died for our sins because jews and
muslims would go hey hey hey we live
here too but america was founded based
on judeo-christian values and principles
do you know that roughly speaking
as minus thomas jefferson being a side
you know
but again read hamilton and madison read
the federalist papers there's no god in
there there's no bible there's no
religion these are all just ideas so so
was there was there god for george
washington was there god for uh was it
why she was a he was a diaz but more of
a believer than jefferson yeah he was
yeah
was definitely not but but but it
doesn't matter what the founders
believed it doesn't matter it's the
ideas i think they came up i told him
yeah oh i totally agree but like you
know
kids going to school would i want the
kids go to a school
that are based on a certain
values and principle that's a higher
power than a man i don't know if
from my record anybody you've given too
much power to you've heard the quote
before power you know corrupts people in
absolute power right need to repeat that
you've heard that a million times i'm
just too concerned about giving men a
little bit too much power absolutely
again ambition must be made again maybe
maybe you like that maybe you like that
maybe you married a german and she
rubbed off on you i don't know you kind
of like a man having too much yeah
okay right my inner niechi
your
let's talk about some other topics we
can get out for religion here by the way
do you what's more important a better
debate or better debater
well the better debate is is the key
it's ideas ideas is i'm interested in
ideas i don't care whether i win a
debate or not it's irrelevant
but you know you know how sometimes you
got a better debater with bad ideas ends
up crushing somebody with a better
debate well see that's the problem
for example christopher hitchens and i
were you know
pretty simpatico on most things but i
wouldn't want to debate him on even
something i knew way more than him about
because if he just took the other side i
know i'd lose
by the way one of my one of my favorite
guys to watch
when there's a debate it's him have you
seen him and his brother
i knew hitch he was a friend of mine
yeah i knew him and my dog's name is
hitch you know there's something about
him that feels very likeable and warm i
don't know like a lot of them
agree with the guy but i like them so is
dawkins and so is sam harris everybody
thinks he's you know
these atheists are militant and and so
no they're not they're actually nice
guys i should think they're necessary
because they can point out the weakness
and the opposing argument and sometimes
strengthen it well that's the point of
debate is if if you can't articulate the
other side yeah your positions then you
don't really know your own position no
question about it no question about it
uh final thoughts on a conspiracy theory
so which conspiracy theory
gave you
the most uh uh of
hard time debunking where you're kind of
like oh my i mean i've heard your 911.
i've heard your john f kennedy i've
heard the
i've heard i've heard a lot of your
debates and you're just like nope this
is what happened no this is no no no but
which one is it where you're like i
don't know there's something there
well at the moment the one we're going
through right now is the lab leak
hypothesis for kovitt uh that that door
is not shut we don't know that could
still be a kind of conspiracy even if
it's an accident uh probably not
intention probably not a bio weapon
development but a gain of function for
other reasons maybe research that leaked
but whatever it is you know and then the
chinese are hiding it you know that's a
kind of conspiracy
uh of which there's a theory about it
and i'm i'm troubled that the fact that
in early 2020 say march april that was a
viable uh conspiracy theory to discuss
and then all of a sudden it wasn't
acceptable to even talk about it anymore
it's considered fake news
uh
and now all of a sudden it's okay again
because jon stewart went on a comedy
show and talked about you know it's like
how is it that a comedian can tell our
society what's acceptable for debate
come on
all right so um
well then a few other well because i i
was uh about the jeffrey epstein death
at first i thought nah no conspiracy and
then you know then when the news came
out about the second camera that broke
down i thought okay come on chances of
that are fairly low so my my priors were
changed my bayesian reasoning went up
that you know
you know changed my priors to the
probabilities being higher that it was
murdered
but then i got an e and i posted this on
twitter and then i got an email from
somebody saying i worked at that prison
those cameras never worked it's a piece
of
prison nothing worked in there i'm like
oh okay never mind i think it just goes
down to prison though did they not like
they just are the closest i think i
think so yeah i think they lost their
funding i don't know what
anyway
uh but but i just finished my next big
book on conspiracy theory so i actually
have several chapters on real ones
you know all the stuff that um between
the pentagon papers and wikileaks uh you
know edward stones snowden stuff
uh about what our government was doing
you know why uh warrantless wiretaps and
surveillance programs not just under
bush but under obama you know mr
president transparency you know there
was a lot of shenanigans going on there
and then the stuff that came out about
um
abu ghraib and you know torture
and you know we still have captured 911
terrorists in guantanamo bay just
sitting there
20 years later and they still haven't
had a trial
that's totally against not only our own
judicial system but the geneva
convention about war crimes and how war
prisoners of war are to be treated i
mean it's just staggering the stuff
that's coming out and now there's new
stuff about uh just coming out like this
week hopefully about the role of the
saudi government and and the saudi royal
family and so on funding
uh the 9 11 terrorists you know that we
then support their regime they're our
allies hang on for a second and this
gets back to them you know michael
moore's crazy no not michael moore sorry
it was i think it was
no that that wasn't michael moore alex
jones conspiracy you know about you know
all the um
uh saudis who left not uh america 912.
you know the the us government said okay
you can leave but all flights were shut
down how did they leave okay
what is the story there come on
you know so forget the 911 truthers and
their inside job that bush did it he he
couldn't he couldn't figure out how to
do any of that
you know
the real story is probably this other
conspiracy
not to mention the two trillion dollars
we spent just in afghanistan six
trillion total uh on both wars and the
whole homeland security
and the surveillance state and all the
loss of civil liberties because of that
all these things that's
that's the true conspiracy right so
don't get uh sidetracked by these 911
truthers they're a distraction from the
real stuff that's going on
even now here we are the second week in
in september of 2021 there's still stuff
that happened we don't know and i think
that's there's something there
9 11 truthers are the real conspiracy
what concerns you more what concerns you
more michael bio warfare cyber warfare
you know or you know what you hear about
the uh you know we were talking to my uh
eric here
uh who you know some are talking about
weather to be able to manipulate weather
you know that's been around for a while
they've been talking about that talk to
a uh inventor who said it's very easy to
manipulate weather if you want to add
larger scale it's a different story what
concerns you the most you so you look
like somebody that would read these
weird books and study
i read all those weird books that's my
my job is studying weird things now the
the only real existential threat that i
see is nuclear weapons you know there's
still over ten thousand uh which is
enough to eradicate the species but
there's nothing even remotely like that
i don't think climate change is an
existential threat i don't think
terrorism is an existential threat but
nuclear weapons are we'd have to get it
down below a thousand nuclear weapons to
prevent like a nuclear winter or
something like that that could be
catastrophic even if it didn't kill
every last human it would you know cause
so such massive suffering that it that's
a concern
and i don't know a way around it because
of the what's called the security
dilemma or the hub easier trap or the
other guy problem you know i want to get
rid of my nukes but the other guy's got
him
you know so if we can't we can't you
know like with north korea we can't
can't let up
and that's always going to be a problem
yeah there's not a solution there
and even if let's just say they say oh
we got rid of everything do you believe
them no
so
so how do you how do you figure that
part out anyway
all right i've enjoyed having you on uh
you know we're going to put the link to
your books below and uh thank you for
taking the time you're welcome thanks
for having me this was quite the
conversation i had no idea what we were
going to talk about so
this worked out great thank you
take care bye-bye okay bye-bye so i'm
curious that man create god or did god
create man comment below i'm curious
from today's and if you like this anyway
i've got two other interviews for you
one of them is when i sat down with
deepak chopra and carlsbad we had a
great conversation together and the
other one is a sit down i had with
dennis prager one of my favorite people
in the world to listen to click over
here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]